use the change of base formula to find
log base 5 of 100 to the nearest
thousandth so the change of base formula
is a useful formula especially when
you're going to use a calculator because
most calculators don't aren't don't
allow you to arbitrarily change the base
of your logarithm they have functions
for log base e which is a natural
logarithm and log base 10. so you
generally have to change your base and
that's what the change of base formula
is and if we have time i'll tell you why
it makes a lot of sense or how we can
derive it so the change of base formula
just tells us that log
and let me do some colors here log base
a
of b
is the same thing
is the exact same thing as as log
base
x where x is an arbitrary base
of b
of b
over
over
log
base that same base base x
base x
over a
over a and the reason why this is useful
is that we can change our base here our
base is a and we can change it to base x
so if our calculator has a certain base
x function we can convert to that base
it's usually e or base 10. base 10 is an
easy way to go and in general if you
just see someone write a logarithm
like this if they just write log of x
they're implying this implies log base
10 of x if someone writes natural log of
x they are implying
log
base e of x and e is obviously the
number 2.71 keeps going on and on and on
forever
now let's apply it to this problem
we have we need to figure out the
logarithm and i'll use the colors
base 5
base 5 of 100
of 100 so this property this change of
base formula tells us that this is the
exact same thing as log i'll make x 10
log base 10 of 100
of 100 divided by
divided by
log
base 10
of 5
of 5. and actually we don't even need a
calculator to evaluate this top part log
base 10 of a hundred what power do i
have to raise 10 to get to 100 the
second power so this numerator is just
equal to 2 so it simplifies to 2 over
log base 10 of 5. and we can now use our
calculator because the log function on a
calculator is log base 10. so let's get
our calculator out
and we're going to get
we want let me clear this
2
divided by when someone just writes log
they're mean they mean base 10. if they
press ln that means base e so log
without any other information is log
base 10. so this log base 10 of 5
is equal to
is equal to two point and they want it
to the nearest thousandth so
2.861 so this is approximately equal to
2.861
and we can verify it because in theory
if i raise 5 to this power i should get
100 and it kind of makes sense because 5
to the second power is 25 5 to the third
power is 125 and this is in between the
two and it's closer to the third power
than it is to the second power and this
number is closer to three than it is to
two but let's verify it
let's verify it so if i take five to
that power
if i take five and let me type in well
let me just type in what we did to the
nearest thousandth five to the two
point
0.861 so i'm not putting in all of the
digits what do i get
i get 99.94 if i put all of these digits
in it should get pretty close to 100. so
that's what makes you feel good that
this is the power that i have to raise 5
2 to get to 100. now that out of the way
let's actually think about why this
property why this thing right over here
makes sense so if i write
if i write
log
base a
i'll try to be fair to the colors log
base a
of b
let's say i set that to be equal to
let's say i set that equal to
some number let's call that equal to c
or i could call it e first well i'll say
that's equal to c so that means
that means that a to the c th power
that means that a to the c power
a to the c power is equal to b
this is an exponential way of writing
this truth this is a logarithmic way of
writing this truth
is equal to b
now we can take the logarithm of any
base of both sides of this anything you
do if there's if you say 10 to the what
power equals this 10 to the same power
will be equal to this because these two
things are equal to each other so let's
let's take the same logarithm of both
sides of this a logarithm with the same
base and i'll actually do log base x to
prove the general case here so i'm going
to take log base x of both sides of this
so this is log
base x of
a to the c power
a to the c power i try to be faithful to
the colors is equal to
is equal to
log
base x
of b
is equal to b
is equal to b and let me close it off in
orange as well
and we know from our logarithm
properties log of a to the c is the same
thing as
c
times
the logarithm of whatever base we are of
a
logarithm of a
logarithm of a
and of course this is going to be equal
to log
base x of b
log base x of let me put it i can just
write a b right over there and if we
wanted to solve for c
you just divide both sides by log base x
of a so you get c
c is equal to
and i'll stick to the color it says log
base x of b which is this
over
log
log base x of a and this is what c was c
was log base a of b
it's equal to log
base a of b let me write it this let me
write it
see let me well let me let me do the
original color codes just so it becomes
very clear what i'm doing i think you
know where this is going but i i want to
be fair to the color so c is equal to
log
base x of b
of b
over
over let me scroll down a little bit
log
base x dividing both sides by that of a
of a and we know from here i can just
copy and paste it this is also equal to
c this is how we defined it so let me
copy it and then let me paste it
so this is also equal to c
and we're done we've proven we've proven
the change of base formula log base a of
b is equal to log base x of b divided by
log base x of a in this example a was 5
b is 100 and the base that we switched
it to is 10 x is 10.